[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partez vite
aller loin
et revenez tard
ces recommandations ont été écrites par
un de mes illustres confrères en 1721
lors son avis de précaution contre la
maladie contagieuse d'hommes marseille
qui ravage alors la ville
sa seule recette pour lutter contre la
peste
débarquer d'orient quelques mois plus
tôt par le navire le grand saint-antoine
fuir fuir
pas de test pas de vaccin pas de masquer
cette pandémie lily à 300 ans exactement
nous rappelle que celle que nous vivons
depuis 20 mois n'est peut-être pas si
exceptionnel
des grands saint-antoine il en vogue il
en vol il enroule des millions par jour
transportant des maladies d'un boutre à
l'eau de la planète en quelques heures
la commune n'est que la énième pandémie
d'une longue série la cinquième depuis
la grippe espagnole de 1918 qui fit plus
de victimes que la grande guerre
d'autres candidats attendent leur tour
vous connaissiez seulement les acronymes
sarce merce ebola il ya quelques temps
non
ils n'attendent que leur moment pour
émerger peut-être et énergie le climat
et on l'a vu tout à l'heure qui se
dérèglent
peut-être en défaveur pour notre santé
la température qui augmente permettent
aux moustiques ne vivent désormais dans
des endroits qui étaient inhospitalier
pour eux ils transmettent le paludisme à
plus haute altitude en afrique les
maintenant ils transmettent désormais la
fièvre dengue maladie tropicale
historique s'il en est sur nos côtes
méditerranéennes 1 étaient sûrs de nos
presque
ajoutez à cela les inondations les dom
de chaleur et vous comprendrez que la
santé du mise à mal par notre climat
notre mode de vie également
nous rend plus fragiles
nous sommes sédentaires
bonjour mal nous malmenons notre sommeil
et nous développons de plus en plus
jeunes les maladies chroniques
hypertension diabète cancer qui tue plus
dans le monde que toutes les maladies
infectieuses réunissent comme les
spécialistes le disent si thing is the
new smoking
le travail également
de mettre notre santé à risque l'ong
sauveur longues heures de travail
pénibilité manque de reconnaissance
précarité tout ceci engendre ma le dos
burn out mais surtout potentiel et ses
maladies chroniques et potentiels
entraînés en accepter les angoisses ou
au pire des pressions et tentatives de
suicides alors tous ces risques pour
notre santé ils sont bien présents ils
sont là peut-être même croissant et la
pandémie les amplifier mais par contre
ce que la pandémie nous a appris et nous
a révélé c'est qu'on peut maîtriser ses
risques et ses enjeux la pandémie nous a
fait comprendre que nous sommes tous
vulnérables collectivement ensemble pour
certains risques tant que le virus
circule nous sommes à risque tant que
l'ère des métropoles que nous respirons
est pollué nous sommes à risque tant que
la fréquence des événements climatiques
extrêmes augmente nous sommes également
mais la pandémie a révélé que nous
sommes surtout vulnérable pour notre
santé mentale en ayant bouleversé
profondément notre mode de vie et notre
façon de travailler
il est donc nécessaire nous comprendre
comment on peut tirer parti de cette
pandémie à travers la promotion et la
prévention de la santé puisque l'on peut
plus fuir que faire
comprendre ce qu'est la promotion de la
santé la provence ou la santé ce sont
toutes les actions qui visent à mieux
comprendre et améliorer notre santé le
lavage des mains contre la maladie
qu'est transmettre ou le dépistage des
caries et cancer à l'école mais
également la prévention pour la santé
est encore plus importante elle vise à
éviter les maladies et leurs
conséquences et la meilleure que l'on
connaisse aujourd'hui c'est la
vaccination contre le rotavirus
alors que non mettre en oeuvre cette
promotion et cette promotion de la santé
au quotidien
et bien en tirant partie
du tiers de notre vie
le tir de notre vie
quand nous additionnons le temps passé
au travail dans les trajets mais
également les tâches domestiques ou les
études supérieures et bien selon les
calculs les experts tout ceci représente
environ un tiers de notre vie comment
tirer parti de cette 30% précieux de
notre temps pour justement mettre en
avant la promotion et la prévention la
santé
alors évidemment tirer parti de la
technologie on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure pour mettre en oeuvre ses
préventions et cette promotion vous
souvenez vous de ces histoires de
mineurs qui descendait avec un canari au
fond des mines
et qui s'arrêtait le chanter lorsque le
taux d'oxydé de carbone augmente elle
est très venant de risque
d'évanouissement ou d'explosion et bien
aujourd'hui
ces détecteurs différents certes mais
sur le même principe n'existe pour
mesurer la qualité de notre
environnement de l'air et donc témoigner
du risque de contamination encore un
navire uss demain d'autres marqueurs
d'exposition intégrer dans nos vêtements
nos casques nos lunettes nos lentilles
de contact nous permettront de prévenir
également contre d'autres risques tels
que les rayons ultra violet ou le risque
de déshydratation en mesurant notre
sueur en continu
dans les endroits dépourvus de médecins
la télémédecine permettra justement
d'assurer cette promotion est cette
prévention de la santé dans des cabines
de téléconsultation imaginez-vous assis
confortablement installé dans un
fauteuil bardé d'instruments nous irons
tous qu'un médecin serai dans cinq
années de la tension artérielle jusqu'à
la couleur de vente errements et
transmettant les informations en direct
à des spécialistes et sans piqûre cela
fonctionne très bien dans des endroits
isolés sont des navires des plateformes
pétrolières demain peut-être dans chacun
des bureaux
est ce aussi valable pour notre santé
mentale
certains managers pour avoir une idée de
la météo du moral de leurs actifs leur
demandent de répondre un message avec
des smileys
bien demain
l'intelligence artificielle
analysera nos émotions
le ton de nos conversations et de nos
emails pour donner une idée du niveau de
stress et de fatigue d'une équipe donnée
mais au delà de la technologie
c'est surtout pas la transformation de
notre environnement
et en apprenant les bons comportements
que pouvons nous pourrons véritablement
promouvoir notre santé
vous êtes petit venu aujourd'hui à cette
conférence en métro et peut-être
avez-vous noté sur les poubelles des
étiquettes marqué c'est pas sorcier ça
ne mange pas de pain bravo et si vous
avez utilisé ses poubelles
ces messages ne ge ont fonctionné vous
n'êtes pas les seuls depuis leur
installation le taux d'utilisation a
doublé
ses notes font appel à différents
mécanismes la réciprocité la norme
sociale la gratification ce sont des
leviers qui permettent de modifier nos
comportements de manière prévisible
sans faire accroc cours à la contrainte
mais plutôt on s'en rappelle à nos
schémas de pensée et bien ces ménages
demain pourrait être appliquée à
modifier à améliorer notre environnement
de travail en toute transparence
évidemment
telle entreprise
afin d'inciter ses employés à marcher à
décider de reprendre l'ensemble de ses
cages d'escaliers de couleurs vives et
claire et en deux temps sur chaque
marche le nombre de calories perdues
depuis le rez de chaussée
sans fermer les ascenseurs
tel autre
afin de favoriser le transport urbain
par vélo a décidé de faciliter et de
former et d'éduquer les employés qui
souhaitent utiliser ce mode de transport
dans une troisième le médecin lui-même
en voir un message personnel aux
employés pour les invités à se faire
vacciner contre la grippe saisonnière et
tout ceci fonctionne
vous avez tous appris à porter un masque
je le vois il a peut être appris à
porter une charge lourd travail
peut-être même à faire du secourisme
demain comment
réagirez-vous face à un ou une collègue
qui fond en larmes subitement devant
vous
la maîtrise de notre environnement
passe par l'apprentissage de ces gestes
de premiers secours en santé mentale
comment entrer en contact avec la
personne et gagner sa confiance les mots
à dire les mots à ne pas dire
les coudes bienveillante également
accompagner la personne pour qu'elle se
fasse prendre en charge demain toutes
ces formations seront assurés par la
réalité virtuelle en nous immergeant
dans ces situations que ce soit un
accident un incident une blessure ou une
personne en détresse afin de vous
apprendre les bons gestes les bonnes
attitudes les bons regard avoir à
l'égard de ces personnes souffrantes ou
blessés
partir vite aller loin revenir tard
ni possible ni réaliste ni efficace
dans notre histoire moderne jamais un
événement tel que la pandémie ne nous a
rassemblé tous autant dans notre
condition humaine nous voilà tous
embarqués dans cette même aventure
sanitaires
les un responsable des autres et si vous
pensez que c'est la responsabilité des
autres des managers des ministres ou des
médecins de s'occuper de cette santé
pour vous peut être visité cette
question
cette responsabilité pour rendre le
travail sûr et sain elle nous incombe
tous
je me taise je m'isole je me vaccine jeu
nous protège
je me forme et je m'informe risques de
santé liés au changement climatique au
travail qui bride j'adopte les bons
comportements et les bonnes attitudes en
me protégeant et en nous protégeant
la prévention et la promotion de la
santé
appuyés par la techno j seront clés pour
faire grandir en nous cette intelligence
collective cette qualité d'âme que nous
avons les uns vis-à-vis des autres à
savoir le soin la bienveillance et amp
est
mal être à demain la voilà
dans ce tiers de vie nous pouvons tous
être promoteurs de santé et vous l'avez
compris le travail qu'il soit hybride ou
non
d'être ce maillon fort de cette chaîne
qui nous prépare aux enjeux de demain il
rendra notre futur soutenable et tout
ceci est porteur d'un immense espoir
parce que ces gestes que nous avons
appris à mettre en place pendant la
pandémie individuellement et
collectivement et qui ont porté leurs
fruits eh bien demain où je dirais
plutôt d aujourd'hui nous pouvons les
mettre en place dès maintenant pour la
santé
de notre planète mais ceci est une autre
histoire je vais
[Musique]
à